turning on
anybody care to join me many thanks no
no thank you how about you tix
yeah michael
i left the castle roll in the oven take
it out any time so this
is about midway through the film and it
was
great fun to i said you're not going to
bring robin
up to your closet upstairs and figure
out
what which of michael's shirts he would
change into
i'm ready for some of your alice i
imagine
[Music]
that makes me so pleased maybe i'll just
serve it before i leave
nobody is going anywhere you're gonna
have schmertz tomorrow you wouldn't
believe
hey one of the things that we that we
did
in the early part of the film is that
peacock chair
is sitting out on the terrace the entire
time and no one sat in it because
in some way they were they were uh
reserving at the throne for harold
yeah the queen bee will be here shortly
yeah
medicine cabinet in a band-aid box
somebody told me it's the safest place
if the cops maybe he does he looks like
he's sitting on the throne
yeah it's very good it's his birthday
you're keeping it in an oregano jar and
matt in his little cocoon
he colonized that little hanging chair
salad
but what i find fascinating watching
this
is breakfast she says amazing violent
event just happened at this party
and we're recalibrating and caring
definitely
says things like hot enough for you well
i think if they
you know the fact that they don't throw
them out is just an
indication of what you know what they
were so terrified i mean
you know they wouldn't they would have
apologized they wouldn't apologize for
dancing together
right not only can he not talk
intelligently about
art he can't even follow from one
sentence to the next
but he's beautiful he has unnatural
natural beauty
did you ever see the painting that we
used to base the palette
it's uh like it's by this american
realist painter named john coke
koch and uh
it's just beautiful painting of these
two men sitting in a new york apartment
with just they're just being lit by
lamplight and
the palette is very the color of your
sweater
and the color of michael benjamin's
shirt are the predominant colors in the
paintings wow although it's
terrible yeah it's really beautiful i
mean how long does it last the entire
part
was at the most it was the only thing
that i showed bill pope the
dp i said i wanted to look like this
really
yeah and the painting is called friend
oh and how can his beauty ever compare
with mine
bill's work is really magnificent i
understand from my mother's rabbi that
it's a knockout
i however cannot seem to locate it for a
gander and if i could
i would sell it in a flat i said this a
lot while watching the film it's
kind of unbelievable to imagine that we
didn't shoot this
on a terrace in new york would you kill
me i agree
what they can do if somebody has
something
you're against that
one might say you have a problem in this
area you can't live with it you can't
live without it
hot stuff come hey you know what one
could murder you
i guess in a way this scene is like
great insurance
i was midway through our run before i
watched
that right
oh we read each other every night on
stage which i didn't really think about
it in those terms
yeah bigger than a breadstick it's a
little down for a little bit
how does the bathroom smell meaner than
i think before it smells
reading is sometimes
your cruelty i think yeah you like big
boy
alan mccarthy and don't hold the mayo oh
m it looks after you the only one who
doesn't eat lasagna somebody a good wife
what is it lasagna looks like
spaghetti and meatballs sort of
flattened out
apparently it was very good yes yeah
that wonderful woman mary who cooked
everything in her kitchen
everything flattened out oh yes harold
truly enviable
as opposed to you who knows so much
about haute cuisine
raconteur gourmet zack's costume looks
even better
you like it eat it right hopes wins
well lou found that beautiful emerald
suit
in a vintage store and it would you know
she knew that it wouldn't make it
through the entire shoot
so she found the fabric and rebuilt it
anybody gonna bring a plate up to allen
yeah oh he's a punching bag
you really are do you like i'm having
seconds and thirds and maybe even fifths
funny i watched this scene and i can
believe easy because we were
at that you're absolutely paranoid about
your parents
and yeah when we well why don't
i mean the terrace itself was was
relatively small
it was so so shooting these scenes
on the take place on the terrace was you
know it was complicated but
that's the brilliance of bill pope
lateness oh that's downright crazy
turning standing before a bathroom
mirror for hours and hours before you
can walk out on the street
and looking no different after christ
knows how this
will be a sin of christ
and creams and masks i've got
the mood of the party has been changed
violently we're headed to
the evil little games it's about to take
the story on the pound
yourself alone you wouldn't have any
more than you've already awarded
yourself
you'd really like me to compliment you
now wouldn't you for how honest you're
being
for being my best friend who will tell
me what even my best friends won't tell
me
you hateful sow and the pills
harold has been gathering saving and
storing up barbiturates for the past
year
i got a goddamn squirrel hundreds of
nimbiatols
hundreds of seconals all in preparation
for
and anticipation of the long it's
wonderful because it really is these two
titans
kind of squaring off and everyone else
is just a bystander
and watching it and there's some sport
in it right i mean there's
you know they're sort of one-upping one
another and then it turns
right there what you say
may be true time will undoubtedly tell
but in the meantime you've left out one
detail
the cosmetics and astringents are paid
for
the bathroom is paid for
the tweezers are paid for and the pills
are paid for
[Music]
[Applause]
blow out the candles mary and make a
wish blow out your candles laura
that little ice skater on top of the
cake during the twirl yeah
good shot this shot right here is just
astonishing to me because
we're on a sound stage
oh that's magical oh where's the card
here this is the best oh from larry
larry why would you put him on the phone
one of andrew's many many ad-libs that
made it into the film
larry what is it the deed to boardwalk
oh gay pawpaws oh
larry it's super it goes up the minute i
get home oh good i don't
get it you cruise atlantic city or
something how much did you pay for him
he was a steel i'm not a steal
i cost 20
and what do you do this little part
makes me a little sentimental watching
the gifts being open
yeah nifty sweater thank you hank
you can always take it back i don't know
why it reminds me the most in the state
version within any other moment like i
guess because how many ways can you open
gifts
but um everybody i don't know maybe it's
because i observed so much in that part
like it's quiet divine
look everybody bejeweled knee pads
you know harold's last name is never
stated in the script and so we had to
come up with something
and mark's best friend that he based
the character apparel on was i was
howard jeffries
so that's where the hj came from
that's beautiful michael what
oh
you're welcome what is it harold
it's a photograph of him in a silver
frame and there's an inscription
engraved and the date
what to say
just something personal
hey bernard what do you say we have a
little music i love that that is the
unanswered mystery
in boys in the band
i mean obviously we had to choose
something because this went out
it's a prop and we had to make a
decision but we'll never tell what it
said
do you remember no
no joe i let it go in one ear out the
other no
in all seriousness though in of all the
big brave moves
that mark put down on paper with this
story
that little one is right up there
because
what an odd little quirky thing you put
in there and
it's so impactful
[Music]
love the little christmas tree lights to
create
the ambiance of a tr of a really
wonderful party
just look at the lights you're having a
wonderful time
[Music]
come on they say you
the frosting on charlie's finger so
great yes sir this whole fist grip of
the wine glass
you have a thousand of those little
touches like that
just barely kind of falling when you try
to stay under something
yeah it looked accidental
and i love that jack made the choice
when he's dancing on his own because
harold was an ice skater
so he dances like he's ice skating
is that the twirl that he
[Music]
it's back dies backward and back
[Music]
[Music]
on set was when i realized i would not
have been
wetted and dried open again
[Applause]
[Music]
but i don't know that we actually did
this more than two or three
i think everyone had about four i love
the zack's just sitting there
harold's just sitting there can't be
bothered
someone left the cake out in the rain